- Hello people, this
is Cigarette Man again.
To all the viewers out there
that may have been viewing some
of my talks and things,
including that young
man named Mr. Anonymous
who's out there,
I hope you'll find this
interview as entertaining
or as intelligent as the others.
Today, I'm gonna talk
about the world changing
into something that we
have never dreamed of
what the future holds.
We won't talk about all
the things like corona
that have attacked our world,
but we will talk about the
way it had affected people,
the school system, the jobs,
the government, the sports world.
For instance, most sports now,
they're wearing masks in sports,
the schools and not getting the education
that they would get back in the day.
We haven't had a lot more tutors.
The voting system is going
through mails and phone calls
and stuff because we can't
walk into businesses no more.
And everyone is scared to come
in contact with each other
because they feel what
might be a danger to them.
But what we must realize, people,
is that life is not guaranteed
to anybody from day-to-day.
So if you ever heard of
that Nita Baker song,
"Ain't no need of worrying
what tomorrow's gonna bring
"because it'll be all
over in the morning."
That song meant that it
wasn't no need to worry
because we don't know if we gonna be here
from one day to the next.
So when you teach your children
how to get along in the world,
you have to teach them to
be educated of the world
but not to fear everything
and not go on with their life.
That be so caught up where they
feel everything is gonna be,
'cause no one is guaranteed
everything in the world.
So we have to survive what we got.
And the changing of the world,
like this guy I met right here,
he came down here,
he don't wear a mask or
anything and we come out here
and we deal with each other every day
and life goes on for us.
The thing about the world today is,
is that everybody's so
stressed out and complicated
and making things so complicated
about what they will have
and what they don't have,
and we got to remember
what life is all about.
Life wasn't meant to be about things.
It was meant to be
about enjoyment in life.
And we keep making it complicated
by putting so much work
and so much time in the
things we don't have
than the things we do have.
Well, let me ask you this
out there to the public,
if you got in your car today
and you saved all that money
in your bank account tomorrow,
whether you got in a car wreck
today and you died today,
then all that would be
obsolete 'cause we both know
in past histories that
kids have killed their parents for money.
We talking about
Menendez,
OJ, didn't wanna give Nicole
Simpson all that money
and now he's in prison or
wherever he's at and has nothing.
Now, the Menendez brothers,
all that money they
wanted from their parents,
they're in prison and
they don't have nothing.
So my point is this,
when you make all that money
and when you do all that stuff
and forget about human life.
You own children,
you ever walk through the
kitchen and see your son staring
at you for some reason
or your daughter is just
staring at you and you wonder
what they staring at?
You actually say, well,
what are you staring at?
Oh nothing, I was
thinking about something.
Do you ever think in your mind
that your daughter was
sitting there wondering,
damn, dad left me 20
million but he's so happy,
mom left me 30 million in the will
but she's so healthy, and when?
So they get there and
they want them Ferraris
and them Lamborghinis now.
We all want things.
And then we get to the drug world.
Drugs have destroyed our world,
not that it's wrong to do them.
'Cause don't get me wrong,
I dibble and dab and I
don't do the hard stuff,
but I have dibbled and
dabbed in drugs too.
But we make it so important to women
and your kids are coming down in Skid Row
to sell their bodies
for crystal, for crack,
and to party.
Is this the life that you really want,
to give somebody that kind of power
and control over your life?
Now again,
remember, again,
I said this once before
in the last interview,
love is truly all the things you hate
and the reason I'm bringing that up today,
because a friend of mine asked me,
he told me how I worded that.
He could remember how I worded that.
Remember, if I loved
everything in the world,
it would be easy for me
to get along with that.
What will be hard for
me to get along with is
when I look across there
at my buddy and say,
you was a nasty son of a B
and then walked out there
and saved his life and let him live,
keep him from dying.
That would be love.
That would be love 'cause
you have concern for life.
The animals out there teach us more
than the humans teach us.
You take the dog, for instance.
The dog is loyal.
He'll sit there all day,
lay and sleep.
But as soon as you come
anywhere near his property
or his owner he's on his feet
and he's alert to everything
that goes on around him.
So my point is,
if we gonna go on and
continue in this world,
remember, education got to continue,
jobs have to continue and
life have to continue,
and it'll be here long after you live.
Now, when I walk the streets
every night and every day,
I'm homeless myself,
and when I walk the streets every day
and every night I see things,
I see people hating each other,
people getting up,
they wanna commit suicide
because they feel like the world...
Now, we talked about this guy,
Donal Trump, like he was a son of a bitch.
But do you remember when all
the stimulus checks came out
and they was getting that money,
we love Donald Trump now.
But when he first got into office,
how could you do it?
But remember why they
put Donald Trump there,
they didn't put him there for ethics.
They didn't put him there for nobleness.
They put him there because the
world was in such a deficit
and they needed somebody
that know how to make money.
Donald Trump showed us that
he know how to do that.
So as much as you think this
man is a son of a bitch,
this man gave a lot of people money.
Ask the GR people with
all them new food stamps.
Ask them people that's getting
all those stimulus checks.
Ask the unemployment people
that's getting them
big unemployment checks
'cause they haven't had no employment.
So, when we say who was the
best leaders of the world?
We go back and think, John F. Kennedy,
Abraham Lincoln, Martin Luther King,
Malcolm X, Robert F. Kennedy,
President Lyndon Johnson.
But what have all those guys did?
Those guys kept us in deficits.
And even though they tried
to help us and be noble,
the world kept us paying
a lot of money out
to other countries for wars and stuff.
Donald Trump will go down
in history as being one
of the guys that made
the world a lot of money
and helped a lot of people,
even though he's a son of a bitch.
The government had to
agree to that and Congress
had to vote on that and Donald
Trump had to sign that bill.
So my point is this,
what do you really want out of life?
That's what most people
have to sit down and decide.
What is it that truly makes me happy?
Is the BMW?
Is it the stress to pay
and bills everywhere?
Is it the stress of your
daughter sneaking out of school,
sneaking to the boyfriend's
home and having sex?
Is it the son that you can't get,
they're leaving Beverly Hills or Bel Air
because he don't wanna run
the company like daddy run it,
he wanted to have fun so
he go down to Skid Row
and spend some, $800.
Pull out $5,000,
then you find his head knocked
off in a ditch somewhere
because the people he
thought he could trust
decided they want more money.
So my point is this, people,
what do you really want out of life
and what does it take
to make you truly happy?
Because if you rely on things,
are you gonna be happy when you have
to send all those bills in?
Are you gonna be happy when
you have nobody around you
but the people that like you for money
and tell you lies that they love you,
and they're really
looking at you in the back
of your head like they wish
you were dead so they can get
to your money?
Who do you trust in the world 100%?
Because not to be in religion,
but in the beginning
of this thing they said
we should appreciate life for life,
not life for things.
Because the things and the goals you set,
we would like to reach these goals,
but what if you don't reach these goals?
Would that put you into a deficit
to where you wanna commit suicide,
to where you feel you
was a failure in life,
because you didn't get
the things you want,
because you didn't have a nice,
big, pretty car,
because you felt like you let mom down
or your brothers and your sisters down,
because you living up to
society's expectations?
Again, I said this once before,
we live up to everybody else's
expectations but our own.
We are trying to do what
everybody else thinks.
Well, I think that would be good for you
to go to this school.
Well, I think this would be good
for you to do this with your life.
Is that what you want to do though?
Because when kids grow up
they decide that I don't like,
my outlook is not the same
as your outlook on life,
whether you're older or younger.
So you have to ask yourself,
where is your life going
and is it going the way you want it to go?
Because once you get older you'll look
in the mirror and say,
well, who am I?
What is it I really wanted to do?
What is it that made me happy?
Was it the girl?
Was it the car, the drugs?
Or was I happy just to
be here another day?
Because I tell you what makes me happy.
What makes me happy is
to see this guy smiling
that's doing the interview again, for me.
What makes me happy is to
see the young lady outside
that's still here and not
going through no headaches.
That's what makes me happy.
Now, if I get a little
something extra along the way
of loving these people and
respecting these people.
See, 'cause beauty starts
from the inside out.
It don't come from the outside in.
If you don't feel beautiful
from when you're in your heart,
if you don't feel like you have a purpose
in life without all that
and that your purpose
for being here is to be happy,
is to enjoy life,
is to make other people happy.
Wouldn't you like people to smile?
Now, I'm one to talk that.
Most of my friends would
say I'm a sun of a bitch.
They will say I'm the most
nastiest man out there,
not because I'm mean,
because I'm very thorough.
But basically, I try to
keep a smile on my face
and bring smiles to others.
But when I deal with people
that's not like that,
I deal with them with
a very thorough hand.
So the ones that have
met me think I'm a sun
of a bitch out there.
Don't think, he's a sun of a bitch,
think he's a very thorough man
who will not be easily mislead.
Because if you think way back when,
when you first started this,
when you took your first drink,
did you do that on your
own or did somebody come up
and say, let's have a drink?
And you say, I ain't never did that.
Well, try this,
you'll like it, Bacardi Rum.
And you think about the first
time you hit that crack pipe.
This person, whoever did
that called you a friend,
called themself your friend.
Did you hit it on your own
or did somebody introduce
that to you?
Because they introduced that to you,
you got to remember this person walked up
and handed you a drug
like a joint of marijuana
and gave you one of the
most dangerous drugs
in the world that would fuck
your life up for 40, 50 years.
Same thing with crystal.
And nine times out of 10 that person
that introduced that to you,
you probably still look around
and call him or her friends.
Like the dealers,
excuse me for talking about this.
I'm not trying to get
away from the subject.
But you take the drug
dealer for a long time.
The women used to pay
everything for those drugs.
But then they got smart.
The beautiful woman decided,
if I get this man to take a hit
then he'll be in my category.
I get all the drugs free.
They threw it in his face.
Now the drug dealer becomes the drug user.
Now he's got two things,
he got to make his money,
support his drug habit
with that crack pipe
and that crystal that is
something very dangerous,
'cause you'll never get off of that.
Then he wants to have the drink.
Then he wants to have the girl.
You know how much money that cost to have
that kind of a party?
Back in the day we used
to have house parties
and clubs and everything was open.
But now, even the club system
and people are getting board.
So now they find in bushes,
abandoned buildings to
get high in and have sex.
And it's not about
disease or about corona,
it's about the way you carry yourself.
Do you ever ask any of these people,
do you show me a test?
See, because now a AIDS test
is like a license for sex, see.
A tuberculosis and Hepatitis A,
B and C test is like a
driver's license for sex, see.
Corona is like a driver's license for sex.
That's what I'm telling you.
Whatever going in your body,
you are putting it there by saying yes
to everything you see.
Oh yeah, we can party.
Oh yeah, I want a bite of that.
Oh yeah, I want a drink of that.
Oh yes, I can do this.
Where is your life going?
Now, you take a guy like
me and this guy here.
He might have family
but I've never seen him
with any family.
I might have family but
I don't have any family.
You can think that but I don't.
So, it's up to us to take care of ourself.
Can you take care of
yourself with all the shit
that's going around in the world?
Will you be able to
make the right decision
when somebody asks you a question and say,
let's do something,
do you slow down and think
about what he just asked you?
Because remember this, people,
if a male or female don't
put a gun to your head
and ask you a question,
then don't blame them and say,
oh, it's your mother
fucking problem like that
because the final word comes from you,
yes or no.
So when we point the finger,
are we really placing the blame?
I went to prison six times.
Never carried a weapon,
never did a robbery.
But the things I went to
prison for were small.
I was naive
and I took deals,
but it was my flaw to say yes
to the deal.
So when I think the people
that did my life wrong,
it wasn't, it was me
that didn't think properly
or get into those books properly
to find out about the law
so I could beat these things.
I say, I got nervous,
I said, yes.
And then by the time you get
older we feel so depressed
'cause we feel the world has let us down
and we feel so ashamed
with the things we said
and did that we never look and say,
but it was all my fault.
And no matter where you come from,
we all have bad stories
and we started out bad.
People had some bad
tragedies in their life.
But if you stay in that
tragedy and feel sorry
for yourself you'll never move forward.
'Cause now, I can say,
I can tell this man, oh God,
no, I ain't got no brothers and sisters.
I ain't got no wife and kids.
My mom and dad died when I was 12
and I just couldn't get it together.
I ain't never had no family.
But what does that do for me?
Nothing but keep me in the
same little slump I'm in.
Or I can say, you know what,
my mother wasn't no slut and no whore.
She wasn't supposed to go out and have sex
and have babies just to give
me brothers and sisters.
Do you understand?
My mother,
she couldn't say,
oh, I ain't ready to die yet
when God called her home.
I'm gonna live a little
longer so my son will
have a good life, no.
It's time for me to go
and you'll have to do the best you can.
I've taught you everything you know,
and she taught me well.
So whatever life,
when you come here and
you tell these stories
about your life,
the way it went,
okay, you get a little
compensation for it.
But now, when you get that compensation,
what do you do with that?
Do you run around the corner
and buy another bag of dope
and spend it all and then say,
I'm broke again?
Or would you rather go buy,
even if it's illegal,
would you rather go buy a
carton of cigarettes and say,
hey, sell single cigarettes,
50 cent a piece,
$10 on a pack.
Or would you rather go buy a
license and open up a little,
you get four, $500,
turn it into $1,000
and get your little booth
selling hotdogs or burgers.
Now, that might not be the job you want,
but it will be a steady income.
It might not buy you
that big house you want,
but it'll keep some dinner in your pocket.
It might not buy that car you want,
but it'll keep some clothes on your ass.
And that's what I'm telling you,
if we quit wanting every
damn thing we see on TV,
the Game Boy, the Xbox, the Jordans.
When we see somebody else,
what do we get, envy.
Everybody's life would not be the same.
And I said this before
in one other interview,
there is no right or wrong
'cause everybody's character
and personality's different.
So you can't get mad if I'm gonna say,
well, why is he doing that?
That mother fucker,
I hate him for living like that.
But that's not your life,
that's his life.
He's not gonna be like you.
She's not gonna be like you.
Some lady I don't know,
why is that slut hanging
around all them men?
Let's find out why are you
really mad at the slut?
Are you mad at her 'cause she's a slut?
Are you mad at her
'cause she's getting
attention you don't get
and that she's very beautiful
and men are admiring her?
Just because she smile with men,
in the daytime and have
a lot of male friends
don't mean she's a slut.
That don't mean she having sex with them.
That means that she's
just a very nice lady
and might be letting them down easy,
don't wanna get the big head
and treat them like shit.
But according to you she's a slut
because you don't have the
character or the personality
to communicate or to
be relaxed like she is
and function like she do, see.
Well, she don't get mad
when she look at you
across the street and say,
well, look at that bitch over there.
She got a big ass house and
two nice cars in her life.
But no one gonna have it all.
You got the nice cars and the big house.
She got the attention.
The slut got the attention of the men
and making her little
money on what she wanna do.
So like I said,
quit getting mad at everything around you
and decide, where's my life going?
All I gotta do is pay attention to me.
'Cause for me personally,
I have so much hard time
taking care of Cigarette Man,
I don't have time to worry about
what the fuck somebody else been doing.
And if you know this,
anybody that know me,
excuse my language on the YouTube,
and I'm just telling the
truth how I really am.
I don't wanna give you no false
hope to say I did not know.
So if you know those people
when they come around me,
the first thing I say,
look at the look in my face when they say,
(indistinct).
What?
When they see that look
they know not to lie to me
and come with no bullshit.
I'm gonna, get the fuck away from me.
I don't wanna hear that.
I'm a man of God and I ain't
down with that bullshit, see.
So you can't get mad at what
everybody else is doing.
When they come at me and tell me, well,
I don't like this about
you, Cigarette Man.
Well, I don't care about
what you don't like about me
'cause you don't have to live my life.
I gotta live it, see.
Because all I'm gonna do is
live and die on this planet
and I'm never gonna have
everything everybody else got
and don't want everything everybody.
My life wasn't meant to cut that way.
But you can't get into me and say, well,
goddam, I want that BMW he drives.
No, I don't want that.
Never even put in for a driver's license.
I want my 21-speed bicycle
that I always rode.
That's what I want.
And so I'm just telling you,
when we walk around we bring
stress in our own life.
And when people say,
I need pills for stress, I'm bipolar.
No, you're not. No, you're not.
You convinced yourself
that you were bipolar.
you were stressed out
because you look around and get mad at
what everybody else has got.
And you get mad
when you think their life
is going better than yours
and your life could be going good too
and going the direction
your life was meant to go.
Your life ain't meant to go like hers.
So if you strike out,
oh, this mother fucking
nigger think he all that,
got the gold chains on and all that there.
The same guy that you see
with all those gold chains,
with all those headaches and
got to go to that big company,
catching them pills on the
wall he take in the month.
He probably looks out his
window at you and think,
I wish I could have a peaceful life like
that guy right there.
Nobody bothers him.
So remember, the things you
don't have could keep a lot
of stress out your life.
And the things you do have will keep a lot
of stress in your life
because the more you got.
You have two people in a crowd
of 10 that really love you.
The other eight are looking
at you thinking in your mind,
how do we get that money?
How do I get this mother
fucker to give me a loan?
How do I get to be a co-signer for my car?
How do I get in his world?
How do I get some of the
stocks in his company?
Ain't but two out of them
10 that say I really,
truly love this person for that person.
Everybody else got some ulterior agenda.
And remember this, ladies and gentlemen,
but more to the ladies,
is that everybody wants something.
Everybody wants something.
I wanna be left the fuck alone
and have everybody
giving me headaches about
what this and that there
and stressing me out.
I don't mind,
what I mean by left alone,
that means if good,
educated people need
some advice or something
that I can help them, yes.
But if I got somebody sitting around me,
trying to steal everything I got,
I'm sitting here,
I'm looking at his face,
looking at him,
I'm looking at the table,
that pin up there.
I want that damn pin.
And as soon as he turns his
back I'm wanna take the pin.
I'm talking to a lady
but she got a little,
short dress on.
I'm still looking at her in the eyes,
I'm looking down between her legs.
Yes ma'am, and we are
gonna take care of that
and I'm gonna sign these papers,
and why are you not looking at me?
Why are you looking down?
'Cause you looking at what you want.
And all we gotta do is sit back
and pay attention to everything
that goes on around us.
And again, I'll say this here,
when you hear me speak like this
you say, this man never went
to school a day in his life.
How do he learn,
and again, no library,
no phone, computer illiterate.
So you say where did he get this knowledge
to speak like that?
Living in different cultures
and paying attention
to what's going on around me.
My point is you don't need,
you would want society to
teach you certain things
and we do need to learn
certain things out of society,
but if you give yourself a chance,
you don't need people
to teach you anything
if you stay focused and
pay attention around you
and read the signs of stores, read signs.
Look at a book and then find
out what that story really
has to give you?
Find out what this Bible,
what that book you're reading
really have to give you?
And if you read it and then you
go out and you pay attention
to every single thing or you just look,
you're just looking,
walking around and looking,
but you pay attention to
all things around you.
Like these high tech cameras here,
I never touched one in my life,
but I guarantee you if you
set one down in front of me
on a stand like that and
I took a look over it,
it might take me a couple of hours,
but I believe I'd be able to work
that thing like a National
Geographic photographer
if I just gave myself a chance, see.
Because we can do
anything we choose to do,
and that don't mean financially.
People say, we can do anything,
but that don't mean you gonna get up
and go make $100 million.
But that mean you can get your mind right.
You know, not genuine,
but I watched the "Star Wars" picture.
"Star Wars" is one of my favorite.
And I asked a guy, I say,
for two cigarettes now you let me see
how good you know your movies.
I say, what did Yoda say to Obi-Wan Kenobi
in the swamps about Luke Skywalker?
Well, I don't know.
I told him, I said,
Yoda said this to Obi-Wan Kenobi.
Now, listen to this.
This is years ago.
I know you think that it's just a movie
but his is what Obi-Wan,
Yoda said to Obi-Wan Kenobi.
And you said, how did he remember that?
All these years later he remembered that.
Yoda
told Obi-Wan Kenobi in the swamp
about Luke Skywalker when
he was young and wild.
He said, the boy cannot learn.
He has no discipline.
And Yoda asked him and said,
was I any different when you taught me?
And Yoda
got the message which means,
the student taught the
teacher something, see.
Yoda was the master.
He had given up 'cause
he got up in his old age.
He was about to give up on Luke Skywalker.
The boy cannot learn 'cause
he has no discipline.
But was I any different
when you taught me?
And Yoda looked up and
did not have an answer
which means the student
that he taught came back
and delivered something to the teacher
and taught the teacher.
Which means anybody can do
anything and will learn.
And that's another thing,
we read books,
we look at movies.
We don't understand what the intelligence
of the movie giving gus.
If you looked at "Star Wars",
the power of the dark
side and the Jedi Knight,
that was heaven and hell
fighting against each other.
That's why they kept saying,
"The power of the dark side."
The emperor was Lucifer coming in.
Luke Skywalker was the angel that God sent
to defeat Lucifer.
So everything's about life,
even the movies that
you see is about life.
The bank robbery in the movie, "Heat",
Downtown Los Angeles.
Robert De Niro and Al
Pacino shooting it out
in the middle of Los Angeles streets.
Remember that thing long
time ago in North Hollywood
where that bank robbery
where they were shooting out
in the middle of the streets?
You didn't get that message
when they killed them two boys
out there in North Hollywood.
They was robbing that bank
and then they come with the movie,
"Heat" years later.
But it was Downtown.
They had to change the
scenario a little bit,
but it was Downtown Los Angeles.
And this was a real life thing
but most people didn't get that.
That was the bank robbery in Burbank,
yeah, in Burbank about 10,
20 years ago when they
killed them two boys
and them guys had the machine
guns robbing that bank,
then years later came with "Heat".
So my point is this, people,
everything pertains to life.
"Ain't no need to worry
"'cause it'll be all
over in thee morning."
And there's another one,
"Baby don't worry,
"Everything little thing's
gonna be all right."
One more, ain't got nowhere to live.
Cigarette Man, ain't got no money.
Ain't got no wife,
ain't got no family.
"But don't worry, be happy."
That's all we can do 'cause
we cannot control the things
we wanna control on this planet.
No one man can control that.
I don't know one female.
We do the best we can in life
and that's all that we do
and then we move on.
And nobody's character's the same.
We've had presidents,
everybody from all the '60s.
Jesus Christ was the first assassination
when they hung him on the cross.
Abraham Lincoln freed the blacks,
they hated him and shot him
in the back of the head.
John F. Kennedy and Robert F. Kennedy,
two brothers were very
noble but they died.
Malcolm X wanted to
stand up for the brothers
'cause they felt like,
and some of the things he said was right
and some of the things he said was wrong,
because he felt like we
wasn't getting a fair hand.
They killed him.
Martin Luther King wanted to
do it a little bit different.
He wanted to go for all the people,
which is a noble thing.
Both men were noble but he wanted
to help the people, period,
but they killed him.
And can't no one person control the world
and if you try
they'll kill you too.
So what my point is, people,
try to live.
Try to be happy.
You got YouTube, you got Facebook,
you got all kinds of things you could do.
You got business.
If you don't wanna do nothing else.
Do you know,
I don't know if I told you
this in my first interview,
but do you know about
25 years ago I wanted
to leave Los Angeles.
About 30 years ago I wanted
to leave Los Angeles so bad.
And I didn't have the money
and one night I walked out
the door and I told my buddy,
I said, I'm leaving in the morning.
He said, well where you going?
How you gonna leave?
I said, I'm gonna take that 10-speed Huffy
and I'm gonna ride that
all the way down 10
to Fort Lauderdale, Florida.
And I did that.
The next morning I got up.
I brought my bike downstairs.
It was on San Julian and 5th Street.
And I got on that 10-speed Huffy.
I left a house full of furniture.
I was in the SRO.
I left a house full of
furniture in there and money
and I'd got on Highway 10
which started over here.
They tell me it started in Santa Monica,
but I thought it started over here just
on the other side of Downtown.
But somebody told me now
that 10 runs all the way down
to Santa Monica but I
didn't start from there.
I started from over here so I thought
that's where 10 started at.
But I took 10
all the way down to the bottom of Florida.
So I got almost to Fort Worden Beach
and I had two flat tires.
And the guy put the bike
on the back of his truck,
he drove me over to his house
and the front fork was broke.
But do you know what this man told me
when he found out where I was coming from?
He said, I'll give you $200 for that bike
and take you to Fort Lauderdale.
I said, but the bike is toe up, sir.
To buy new forks for that
bike you'd would have
to buy a whole new bike.
You just can't buy new forks for the bike
'cause the bike is split with the forks.
He said, I don't care what
you say about that bike,
that bike got a lot of history
and I'll give you $200 and buy
you a ticket for that bike.
And he did.
I never saw him again but he
was a good man, white guy.
He was a damn good man.
And when I left that night,
I mean, the next day,
he shook my hand.
I knew then this would be
the one and only time me
and this guy would meet.
But he fed me and took me in his house
and didn't know me from Adam.
I could've been a killer
coming across that highway.
I could've been a ruthless person.
He did not even know.
But he opened his house
to me and then he went in
and laid down in his
bed and closed his eyes
and had a good night's sleep on a man he
had never met in his life,
a black man.
Not that the color would
matter but I'm just saying,
I threw that in there because
back then there was a lot
of animosity between
different races, Spanish,
blacks and whites.
There was a lot of animosity.
And this happened at a
time when the animosity
and the stress level was great.
So this was years ago.
So for him to do that
to me was a very noble thing
because he didn't know me from Adam.
And I could've woke up that
night and did anything,
set his house on fire,
killed him, anything.
But I made $200 and I have
made a little money all the way
down the highway.
But my point was I rode
that 10-speed down there,
oh, by the way,
there was two cops that told me,
two highway patrols told
me I couldn't ride the bike
on the highway.
But once they found out
where I was riding from,
do you know these two people,
these two officers gave me a free pass,
not at the same time,
one in Arizona and one in Florida,
and they gave me a free pass.
And there wasn't nobody handing me water,
wasn't no TV thing,
wasn't no publicity stunt,
I just did it.
And so
my point is if we dig deep inside us,
if we dig real deep,
there's something deep inside you
that's waiting to come out.
You gotta wake it up.
You gotta bring it up out of you.
It's in there.
But if you think it's not and
you let people put you down
or make you feel worthless,
you will never find it.
It'll be like Godzilla
was sleeping in the side
of that mountain.
He broke out the side of that mountain,
the monster of monsters defend all public,
hero of monsters.
And when you wake up,
when you wake up with inside of you,
it'll break out you
just like Godzilla broke
out the side of that mountain.
I asked a dude one time a stupid question.
I said, can you tell me
what king beat a god?
He went to try to figure
out Thor beat Hulk or
Zeus beat this.
I said, no, it's simple.
Don't look for nothing complicated.
See, we take things simple
and make it complicated.
I asked him, I said,
what king beat a god?
Quit looking for the complicated thing.
Think of something simple in your mind.
He said, well, I don't know.
I can't figure that out.
I said, you never saw the movie,
"King Kong Vs. Godzilla"?
He looked at me and laughed.
I said, that's because
you look for something that's complicated.
"King Kong Vs. Godzilla",
what king beat a god?
(Cigarette Man coughing)
So my point is
when you rush your car to the mechanic,
if you look up under that hood
you say, damn,
all I had to do was tap that?
But some guy charged you $300 to go
and just hit something with a hammer.
Bing, it's ready.
Or some lady paying
a guy
$50 to fix her flat tire
which she really couldn't
afford that 'cause (indistinct).
But she worried about her nails.
Oh no, my nails.
I can't ruin my nails.
If you wanna pay a goddam genius to jack
that hammer up and put
that thing under the car
and jack it up,
forget those little pretty nails
and save yourself some money.
Roll that tire on and
then put it on there.
Pay attention now when you take
your car to a mechanic shop,
look at what that man doing.
Don't sit there and say,
oh, I gotta make an appointment.
Okay,
make your appointment
and when your car break down again,
bring it back to me so I can
get another $1,000 from you.
Don't look at what I'm doing.
Don't pay attention to
what's happening right here.
Oh, I've gotta have the
babysitter take care of my kid.
I can't go,
I'm going to Europe, bam.
Okay, you do that.
Oh, where you?
Oh, I can't come home
now 'cause I'm on my way
to Russia now for the big meeting.
Oh, I can't do that 'cause
now I've got a meeting
in Spain and I'll be
in New York next week.
And all this time
your child is around that babysitter,
she's feeding her, loving her,
nurturing her, getting to
know her and then you wonder,
why do my child go to you like that?
Why do my child love you like that?
Because that's what she know.
You just the mother fucker
that brought her in the world.
That's the one that's been loving her.
The child going to where you love her,
to the ones who have been loving her.
You was in Spain, Russia,
Rome, New York,
all year long, gone.
You're just another woman to that child.
Just like the dog,
you feed a stray dog food or a stray cat,
it will come back to you every time.
So the things you gonna love
is the things that you know,
the things you come up around,
the people who's been good to you.
So remember to the mother
that's got the babysitter out there,
when you look at your
daughter or your son and say,
why you act so cold to me, son?
Have you ever been around
and do we even know you?
Did he grow up with you?
Was you always in Russia,
Rome and all that,
gone for two or three
years at a time or four,
five months out of the year?
And then when you came
back you was only at home
for a week before you had
to get up and go again
and you think if you gave him a few kisses
and say I love you and
took him to the store
and buy him a new pair of
Jordans or a new bicycle that
that made that right.
Love comes from the inside, baby.
And remember, love is
all the things you hate.
Goddammit, I hate I gotta
stay here with my car,
I can't go make that meeting.
Goddammit, I hate I can't go over there,
I can't go over here
because I gotta do this.
Now you're loving 'cause
you're doing the right thing
and you're doing what you got to do,
not what you want to do.
See, anybody can do what they wanna do,
but can you do what you
gotta do when the time comes,
which you know you got and need to do?
'Cause if we just did what we wanna do,
that will be easy.
I can just do what I want.
I can walk down the
streets and smoke crack,
don't have to worry about nothing.
I can just jump in my car go,
it ain't nothing.
Who comes home and I got to love my child
or nurture my grandmother
who I took care of,
or nurture my mother who have taken ill
and can't get out the bed?
Or wanna tell my brothers,
you take care of mamma.
That ain't my job.
It ain't my day to take care of mamma.
I stayed home with her all day yesterday
or I stayed home with
dad all day yesterday.
It hurts you that bad to
stay home and take care
of your parents that got old,
that's in a wheelchair
and can't get out of bed?
And then you ask yourself,
how bad did it hurt them
when they sent you to school
for all those years and
paid your college education
and fed you, paid your rent,
bought your clothes?
Would they act like that towards you?
But you wanna put them
in a convalescent home,
get rid of them,
give somebody else the responsibility
that you know you should have,
because I'm too busy,
I gotta work, I gotta do this.
You gotta do everything
but take care of the people
that you love and take care of your life.
Everything is important
to you but that life
that you carried for 9 months
and went through all that pain
and brought her in the world,
him in the world and now
you don't even have time.
If you know this,
when we have little puppies,
we love little, cute,
sweet puppies and kittens.
They're so playful.
We love him, he's so cute.
Even babies, they so cute.
And when you get grown
the dog sits in the corner
and nobody pats it no more.
The cat just lay around lazy
now that it's a grown cat.
Get up, meow,
walk around the floor and eat.
The kid, sit down,
talk to your son.
You just a nothing ass loser.
I don't love you no more.
Get out of my house.
Oh bitch, you ain't
shit since you grown up.
You just old slutty ass whore.
But way back when,
she was so cute and so pretty and so nice
because then you didn't have
too much responsibility.
All you do is go in and change her diaper
and give her a milk bottle.
But now that you got to
put a little work into it,
I don't love you no more now.
It's too hard.
You making me think too hard.
You making me work too hard to love you.
Ain't that what love's
supposed to be about?
Ain't that what love is?
I love some little bitty
baby that can't tell you,
mom, I hate that.
You ever seen a baby crying?
(Cigarette Man imitating crying baby)
You wonder why she won't stop crying?
That's how we ever looking
up and you and saying,
fuck you, I can't talk yet.
I'm crying 'cause you a
stinking sun of a bitch
that treats me like this,
neglect me with your
boyfriend in the living room.
I'm in here hungry,
needing my milk bottle.
That's the baby's way of saying,
I need some God dog gone attention.
You ain't giving me enough.
I'm your child.
But you wanna play like
she can't understand that.
And you know what the baby means.
You intelligent enough
to know that baby crying
and needs some attention
and needs something
but you too lazy.
She cry all night.
Well, what you think a baby gonna do?
Why didn't you tell that
man to put on a condom
if you didn't really want this.
Your decision to bring her into the world.
If you let him bust in you
and if it's your husband
then that's the way it's supposed to be.
But if it's some boyfriend or
some little dude out there,
you did that being irresponsible,
letting him bust all
up inside you like that
and now you got the baby
and you don't want a baby.
And the same thing with the dad.
Niggers, you too hard.
I'm gonna run.
I got to divorce you.
I can't take care of all them kids.
But you couldn't worry about that
when you was putting
your thing up in there,
busting all up in the woman?
But now you wanna leave
your children at home
and go out and cheat on
your wife with another woman
or use your drugs
to leave reality
and take a flight,
as they say,
get drunk to lose the
responsibilities you have.
The problem with that is is
when you take that flight
and go up,
whatever goes up must come down.
That problem's still there.
When you come off that alcohol binge,
that problem is still there.
When you put that crystal
down and that crack down
that took you from reality,
that problem is still there.
How do you get away?
You don't.
You face it.
You take care of your children.
You love your wife or respect your wife,
even if you don't love here
no more and you all divorce.
You help that woman
take care of them kids.
You help that man take care of them kids.
And remember, if you
want that big old house,
you can have that.
If you want that bigger
house with the five bedrooms
and three bathrooms,
a big back yard,
you can have that.
But
when it comes time to pay for that,
the mortgage, the water bill,
the light bill, the property tax,
don't get angry 'cause
this is what you wanted.
Blame yourself for that.
But I can't afford that
and I'm not gonna get angry
at somebody else that can
'cause we got different lives.
Their life took that turn, mine didn't.
But it's not for me to
get mad and get jealous
'cause I can't have that.
And the bottom line,
I didn't want it, no way.
I probably could've had it
but the reason I felt
like I couldn't have it,
because I could not
meet the responsibility
of taking care of this thing
and taking care of this.
Like a woman,
upkeep, gas,
insurance, responsibility,
driver's license.
Now, if you can handle that, that's fine.
But if you can't handle
that and you're trying
to live a life,
live above your means or
you're trying to live a life
that somebody else said you could do,
remember, you didn't do
it because you wanted to,
you did it because somebody else suggested
that you could do this.
I'm gonna add it up pretty good.
And I have to cut this thing off.
But I got a few more things to say
but I'm gonna cut this down pretty much
'cause there's other people,
other things this guy have to do today.
But maybe not in the next month or so,
but in the next month or
two you'll probably hear
from me again.
But remember, people,
everything we do in life,
if a male or female didn't
have a gun to your head,
it was your decision.
Get mad at yourself because
you had two answers to say.
You could've said yes
or no.
Those are your options.
And if you want that big old car,
get that if you can feel
like you can have that.
If you want that big mansion
in Bel Air or Beverly Hills,
or even if you just want
the five or six bedroom
in Santa Monica (indistinct),
you can have that.
If some of y'all just wanna go
on that exotic cruise vacation,
you just take a cruise.
That costs you about a
half a year's salary too.
So if you pay to go on that cruise
will you have enough money
to feed your kid next week?
Will you have enough money
to make the car payment?
You take four, five thousand,
$10,000 to go on a cruise
and with all the extras,
lay on the back, smiling,
sip on margaritas,
living high on that ocean.
And then as soon as you touch
land you got bill collectors
lined up from here all
the way to New York.
Oh, you went on that cruise,
we gonna reposes this.
Oh, we gonna reposes that.
Live your life,
don't try to live the life of others.
It'll never work.
There is no right or wrong.
Everybody have different characters,
different personalities,
we all think differently.
And even on this interview
there'll be some that like it
and there'll be a lot or some that say,
fuck that, he wrong.
I don't agree with that,
and that is the human way.
That is the nature of life.
We cannot blame everybody else
for decisions we make in life.
And one other thing I
gotta say, remember this.
Every decision you make in your life,
you will be held accountable for that
whether it's today or next year.
But somewhere, something you said yes to
or no to will come back to bite you
and you'll say, damn that.
God, if I had said no to that last week,
now I got to pay this damn bill over here
all because I let this
idiot talk me into spending
that money last week.
Your decision, you said yes or no to that
and you did not think it properly.
And if you had something
to do a week later,
for that moment it left your mind
and you didn't think about it,
not until you got in a hole
that you could not dig your way
out of and then you wanted to
point the finger at the world.
No sir,
it's not anybody's fault in the world
that Cigarette Man don't have
any brothers and sisters.
It's not anybody's fault
that Cigarette Man doesn't have a car.
My fault.
It's not anybody else's fault
that I don't have no wife and kids.
It's not anybody's fault
that my mother died at 12.
I was 12 years old.
That's not nobody's fault,
not even mine.
That's just what happened
at that point in my life.
So if I was left here by myself,
she didn't intensionally do it
and it was no one else's fault.
And if there is a God in
heaven which I do believe,
but everybody don't believe
the same way I believe,
so I don't push religion on you.
But if there is one up there
then that was his decision to do that
and we don't question him.
And we all believe in something,
so you don't have to
believe in what I believe,
just get an understanding of your own life
and believe what you believe.
Because in the end,
whether there is one up there, remember,
it said in that book you
picked up a long time ago,
he is your only judge,
no one else.
And people are gonna make you feel guilty
in life so they can control you.
So they gonna try to make you feel guilty
on everything they do,
make you feel like you owe them,
make you feel like you doing something,
that they done so much for you
that you owe them your life,
you owe them everything.
And you owe no one nothing.
Because if there is a God in heaven,
he had to give them life,
they wouldn't have been able
to give you what they gave you.
So everything you got,
from my belief,
you got it from God.
That's my belief.
That doesn't have to be your
belief or what you believe in
but that's where you got it from.
Because if I didn't wake up today,
I couldn't do this interview.
So whatever I'm giving you
through this interview,
which I hope you will
find some things in it
that will help your life
better and make it easier,
and for the ones who don't, I'm sorry,
I did the best I could do.
But the only thing I'm giving you
is me, and I'm really not giving you that
because if He hadn't
have woken me up today,
this interview would've never took place
and you would've never
heard from me again.
Have a good day, people.
Maybe we'll talk again
in about a month or two.
We'll see you and I hope
what you heard today will help a lot
of you people's lives out
out there and make it better.
And don't blame anybody
for the things you say
yes and no to, goodbye.
Oh, one other thing,
what was the guy's name?
- [Interviewer] Anonymous Anonymous.
- Okay, and to Mr. Anonymous,
thank you and I hope you
find some things in this
that you like and I hope
you find this interview
is just as good as the others.
And maybe in a month or
two when I walk around
and see some things I need to talk about,
I'll be back again if
God's will I'm alive.
Until then, Mr. Anonymous and all the rest
of society and the world out there,
enjoy your life and have a good day.
Cigarette Man, out.